cinéma avec cette légende fantastique
mise en scène par tim burton amende de
conte de fées merveilleux
cauchemardesque que traverse avec talent
johnny depp déjà un succès aux états
unis pour le réalisateur de batman et
mars attacks
pascal deschamps imaginez-vous enfants
dans votre lit vos parents vous lisent
un conte plein de sorcières et de forêt
hantée c'est ainsi que les petits
américains ont grandi avec la légende du
cavalier sans tête
c'est ainsi que tim burton la restitue
aujourd'hui en rendant hommage aux films
d'horreur les années 50
jali depp interprète un jeune inspecteur
de police qui débarque dans un village
terrorisé enquêter sur les meurtres de
sibiu que vous honte expliquer vos
supérieurs
ils ont dit que tous les trois ont été
tués en plein air et que leurs têtes
avaient été séparés de leur corps
emportés par le cavalier seul en tête
puisque leur enfer avec lui washington
un ring est née je pense que si
washington irving l'auteur du compte vu
imaginions 18 120 que son histoire
serait un jour porté sur le grand écran
au fait que s'ils en avaient rêvé
alors il aurait sûrement choisi tim
burton pour réaliser le film
on dirait que cette histoire a été
écrite pour lui
vous avez déplacé le corps se fait déjà
il ne faut jamais déplacé le corps
pourquoi dans parce que tim burton s'est
régalé en recréant un univers
fantastique où s'affrontent le bien et
le mal le surnaturel et le rationnel et
s'il ya de la violence dans sleepy
hollow
c'est celle des contes de fées
l'agresseur arrangements et abat du mas
balle il a fait volte-face
est revenu sur ses pas s'emparer de la
tête du malheureux les comptes de ce
genre sont le moyen le plus sûr
d'exorciser nos zones de l'équipe en
plastique qui ne prétendent pas être
réaliste servez la même chose moi j'ai
un problème avec une autre forme de
violence
par exemple quand deux types branchés se
tirent dessus en échangeant des blagues
hofland autres aux gens pour moi celle
là est beaucoup plus dangereuse selon
tim burton signe là un petit bijou du
film d'or ont ri ont tremblé lorsque les
lumières se rallument on se dit que
c'est bon de retrouver ses peurs
d'enfant